Some shrimp are unusually scrappy fighters.
Pistol shrimp and a few dozen others
can snap their claws shut at ultrafast speeds.
The claws close so fast that it boils
the water around them, creating tiny air bubbles.
The force of the water pressure crushing the bubbles
generates a shockwave that stuns the shrimp’s prey.
How claws that evolved for simple pinching
gained the ability to close so quickly
was a mystery to biologists.
A team of researchers looked closely at
the claw anatomies of 114 shrimp species.
They found two types of claw joints
that no one had noticed before.
The first was a basic slip joint,
like you’d find in a Swiss Army Knife.
A tiny ridge creates pressure as the claw
closes,
allowing it to snap shut a little more quickly.
That basic slip joint set the evolutionary stage
for a further modification: the cocking slip joint.
With this joint, the ridge cocks the claw fully open,
building up tremendous muscle tension
before the shrimp releases it.
The scientists 3D-printed models of the various joints
and found that a claw with a cocking slip joint can snap
closed with enough force to generate shockwaves.
So maybe now you’ll think twice
the next time you go toe-to-toe
or claw-to-claw with a pint-sized pistol shrimp!